>> HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
LAST WEEK.
>> (cheering)
>> LET'S GO.
>> I AM HERE
FOR THE SEMIFINALS
FOR "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
>> SOME TOUGH DECISIONS
HAVE ALREADY BEEN MADE,
AND SOME OF YOU
AREN'T GOING TO PANEL.
>> UNFORTUNATELY,
YOU GUYS HAVE TO GO HOME NOW,
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO FAR...
BECAUSE YOU'RE HOME!
>> (cheering)
>> OH, MY GOD.
THEY TRICKED US.
>> (screaming)
>> AAH!
>> YOU GUYS ARE GONNA BE WALKING
ON A 12-INCH WIDE RUNWAY
IN ONE OF THESE PLASTIC BUBBLES.
OWN IT!
>> WHOOP!
>> (gasps)
>> OHH!
>> TWO BEAUTIFUL LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME.
>> WHEN I LOOK AT THE FACE
AND I LOOK AT THE PICTURE,
THAT'S WHAT MODELS
ARE BOOKED FOR,
AND I WOULD NEVER BOOK A GIRL
WHO LOOKED LIKE THIS.
>> AND ANGELIA WAS SENT HOME.
13 GIRLS ARE LEFT,
BUT ONLY ONE
WILL HAVE CONTRACTS
WITH IMG, COVERGIRL,
AND APPEAR ON THE PAGES
OF ITALIAN "VOGUE."
WHO DO YOU THINK
WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ON TOP ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
>> ♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> YOU WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ IT'S TIME TO MAKE IT HOT ♪
♪ GET IT UP ♪
♪ YOU KNOW ♪
♪ THAT WE DON'T STOP ♪
♪ NA, AND WHEN YOU GET IT HOT ♪
♪ NA, YOU GOTTA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
WANNA BE ON TOP?
WHOO!
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
(static hisses)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WOW!
>> OOH, I LIKE HIS WORDS.
>> "SEXSATIONAL."
>> (laughs) I KNOW.
HE WAS JUST...
>> AH! NIGEL CALLED ME "SEXY."
I WANT--YOU KNOW,
I WANT TO TELL MY MOM.
LIKE, MY MOM WILL DIE
WHEN SHE HEARS--HEARS THIS.
I WAS ADOPTED.
YOU KNOW, MY PARENTS ARE
THE REASON THAT I'M HERE TODAY,
AND SO I REALLY OWE
A LOT TO THEM
FOR BEING ABLE TO DO THIS.
AND IT'S SURREAL, BUT I GOT
THE FIRST BEST PHOTO
IN THE FIRST PANEL.
>> YOU WERE STANDING UP THERE,
NOT EXPECTING
YOUR NAME TO GET CALLED.
THE NEXT TIME
YOU'RE STANDING UP THERE,
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE THE GIRL
STANDING THERE LIKE...
"I'M GOING HOME."
BEING UP THERE, LIKE,
YOU'RE NOT.
LIKE, YOU'RE GETTING
THAT PICTURE.
>> TYRA TOLD ME IN PANEL
THAT I LOOKED TOO OLD
IN MY PICTURES.
>> WHEN I LOOK AT YOUR FILM,
YOU LOOK 15 YEARS OLDER
THAT YOU ARE,
AND THAT'S NOT A GOOD THING.
SO THE THING THAT
I'M GOING TO WORK ON
THE MOST THIS WEEK IS
TRYING TO LOOK MORE YOUTHFUL,
AND THAT'S JUST PART
OF MY PERSONALITY.
I'M A PERFECTIONIST.
>> SO I'VE BEEN WAITING ALL DAY
JUST TO GET HOME.
>> JUST TO SIT DOWN?
>> YEP.
>> BUT I WISH I COULD
WATCH A MOVIE OR SOMETHING.
YOU GOT BROTHERS AND SISTERS?
>> TWO OF MY BROTHERS DIED.
>> THIS YEAR,
MY BROTHER WAS MURDERED.
I MEAN, WHO COULD GET OVER
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED
IN THEIR LIFE THAT'S SO TRAGIC?
IT'S HARD.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
IT ACTUALLY MADE ME
EVEN MORE EAGER TO BE OUT HERE.
AND JUST LIKE,
OKAY, YOU GOTTA DO THIS,
YOU KNOW, BECAUSE YOUR BROTHERS
NEVER GOT TO DO IT,
SO YOU HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING BIG WITH YOUR LIFE.
>> HONESTLY, I'M SURPRISED
THAT YOU'RE STILL HERE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
LIKE, I MEAN, I KNOW IT'S BEEN,
LIKE, A COUPLE OF MONTHS
OR WHATEVER,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, LIKE...
>> I MEAN, YEAH, I FEEL...
(speaks indistinctly)
>> YOU WOULDN'T EVEN EXPECT
SOMEBODY TO STILL BE HERE.
>> MY FAMILY IS
THE CENTER OF MY WORLD.
I DON'T KNOW HOW I WOULD BE ABLE
TO HANDLE THE DEATH
OF MY TWO BROTHERS ALONE.
ONDREI--I JUST DON'T KNOW
HOW SHE'S HANDLING IT.
SHE'S NOT REALLY SHOWING MUCH...
OF ANYTHING,
AND IT ALMOST SCARES ME
A LITTLE.
(horns honk)
>> Y'ALL WANNA SEE
MY DIET AS A MODEL?
SO I ONLY EAT, YOU KNOW,
NOODLES AND TORTILLA CHIPS.
AND EVERY NOW AND THEN,
I'LL PUT A LITTLE SYRUP AND...
>> AAH!
>> (imitates French accent)
ZEE
GIRLS! HOW IS THE BÉBÉS?
>> THESE TWO CHEFS
WALK INTO THE ROOM,
AND I'M LIKE, OH, MY GOD!
OH, MY GOD! IT'S TYRA!
>> ZISPRETTY LADY...
>> (laughter)
>> HER NAME IS HEATHER BAUER.
SHE IS A NUTRITIONIST OF ME.
>> OH!
>> SHE TEACH ME
HOW TO EAT BETTER FOR MY BODY.
AND TODAY,
WE ARE GOING TO FEED YOU.
>> I'M LIKE, OH, MY GOODNESS.
TYRA'S IN OUR DIRTY-ASS KITCHEN.
LIKE, UGH.
>> (normal voice) THERE'S, LIKE,
ALL THESE FOODS
THAT PEOPLE THINK, LIKE,
"OH, MY GOD,
YOU SHOULD NEVER EAT...
THAT'S TOTALLY FATTENING
OR TOTALLY BAD FOR YOU,"
AND THEN THEY CHOOSE
THESE OTHER CHOICES.
BUT HEATHER CAME UP WITH
SOMETHING CALLED "CHEATIES,"
WHICH ARE THINGS
THAT "SEEM" BAD BUT AREN'T.
AND AS MODELS,
I FEEL IT IS IMPORTANT
TO NOT DEPRIVE OURSELVES,
BUT TO INDULGE.
>> THEY'RE GONNA TALK TO US
ABOUT THINGS
THAT WE COULD INDULGE IN
THAT WE WOULDN'T HAVE
THESE GUILTY FEELINGS ABOUT
AFTERWARDS,
WHICH IS DEFINITELY AWESOME
TO KNOW ABOUT.
>> (imitates French accent)
SO I AM GOING TO FEED YOU,
AND WE PLAY A LITTLE GAME.
COME HERE, LITTLE LADY.
>> WE'RE GONNA TRY SOME FOODS.
WHATEVER YOU THINK IS BETTER,
YOU'RE GONNA TELL US
WHAT THE ANSWER IS.
>> HEALTHIER.
>> OKAY? EXACTLY. EXACTLY.
>> WHAT IS HEALTHIER?
>> I'M SO SCARED.
>> (normal voice) OKAY.
(drumroll, bell dings)
>> WHICH ONE HEALTHIER?
>> THE SECOND ONE.
(buzzer sounds)
>> EGGPLANT IS GOOD FOR YOU,
BUT IT ABSORBS A LOT OF OIL.
AND PARTICULARLY THIS DISH,
THEY--THEY END UP FRYING IT.
SO THE SPAGHETTI AND MEATBALLS
WINS BECAUSE YOU CAN
GO FOR THE MEATBALLS,
GET YOUR PROTEIN IN.
YOU'VE GOT IRON IN IT,
WHICH AS A MODEL IS
REALLY IMPORTANT
'CAUSE THAT'S WHAT
KEEPS YOUR HAIR REALLY HEALTHY.
>> (normal voice) OKAY,
NOW I HAVE TO CONFESS THAT
WHEN I GO OUT TO RESTAURANTS
AND IT'S AN ITALIAN RESTAURANT,
I'M LIKE, "EGGPLANT PARMESAN.
IT'S MY VEGETABLE."
>> (laughter)
>> SO I JUST LEARNED
SOMETHING TODAY.
OKAY.
(bell dings)
>> OOH!
>> I BITE WITH YOU. UNH.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> YEAH. COME ON.
>> LEAN IN. LEAN IN. LEAN IN.
>> THE GAME THAT
TYRA AND HEATHER HAD US PLAY
WAS WE WERE BLINDFOLDED,
TESTING TWO DIFFERENT PLATES
OF FOOD,
AND GUESSING WHICH IS HEALTHIER.
>> TWO.
>> WHICH ONE?
(buzzer sounds)
(bell dings)
>> PEANUT BUTTER'S
SUCH A GOOD FAT FOR YOU GUYS.
BAGEL AND CREAM CHEESE--
IT'S GONNA FILL YOU
FOR, LIKE, A MINUTE AND THEN
YOU'RE GONNA BE STARVING
FOR THE REST OF THE DAY.
YOU'VE JUST LEARNED TODAY
YOU CAN EAT REALLY GOOD FOOD
AND YOU CAN FEEL YOUR BEST.
>> A CHEATIE DOES NOT MEAN
YOU EAT IT EVERY DAY.
>> EXACTLY.
>> THIS IS WHAT YOU EAT
WHEN YOU WANT TO INDULGE.
>> EXACTLY.
>> OKAY, SO IT'S ABOUT SAYING,
"YOU KNOW WHAT?
I JUST HAD A ROCKIN' PHOTO SHOOT
AND I WANNA CELEBRATE."
CELEBRATE THAT MOMENT, OKAY?
AND THEN RIGHT AFTER THAT,
YOU GO BACK TO
THE HEALTHY THINGS
THAT YOU ALL KNOW.
>> I'M REALLY, LIKE,
ALL FOR TYRA TO, LIKE,
EMPOWER WOMEN LIKE THAT.
I HAVE EXPERIENCE
IN AGENCIES TELLING ME, LIKE,
"YOU NEED TO LOSE WEIGHT."
BUT IT'S MUCH MORE IMPORTANT
TO BE HEALTHY THAN SKINNY.
>> BYE, EVERYBODY.
>> BYE!
>> THANK YOU!
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I FEEL LIKE I WANNA MAKE
A BIG CELEBRATION FEAST.
>> ME, TOO.
>> WHAT IS THIS?
THIS IS DISGUSTING.
>> IT SMELLS LIKE...
>> THAT'S CHICKEN?
>> BARBECUE CHICKEN
THAT'S NOT COOKED.
>> OH, MY GOD.
I NOTICED RAW CHICKEN
SITTING, LIKE,
IN SOME TIN FOIL.
THIS IS FRICKIN' NASTY
AND THIS NEEDS TO GET
OUT OF MY FACE RIGHT NOW.
>> WHAT'S THIS?
THIS WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
IN THE FRIDGE.
WAS THIS IN THE FRIDGE?
>> YEAH, BUT FOR, LIKE, DAYS.
>> IF YOU'RE NOT GONNA
EAT IT RIGHT AWAY,
IT NEEDS TO BE PUT
IN A FREEZER BAG
AND PUT IN THE FREEZER.
>> UM, I'M SORRY.
PLEASE DON'T TALK TO ME
LIKE THAT.
>> WE'RE JUST SAYING--
>> I KNOW. I DON'T NEED
A LESSON ABOUT CHICKEN.
>> THIS RAW CHICKEN
DOES NOT BELONG IN A BOWL
THAT WE EAT CEREAL IN.
IT NEEDS TO GO
IN A PLASTIC BAGGIE.
>> I KNOW ABOUT CHICKEN. I COOK.
>> THEN WHY ISN'T IT
IN THE FRIDGE?
>> DALYA?
BEING 21,
I KNOW HOW TO DO THINGS.
I'M... (mutters)
NO, I DON'T NEED YOU,MISSY.
OKAY, TO BE POINTING
IN MY... FACE AND TELLING ME
HOW TO WRAP... DAMN CHICKEN.
I COMPLETELY KNOW AND UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU'RE SUPPOSED
TO WRAP CHICKEN
BEFORE YOU PUT IT IN THE FRIDGE.
THERE'S NO REASON TO...
CONFRONT ME LIKE THAT.
OKAY, WALK AWAY.
>> THAT RIGHT THERE IS ANNOYING.
>> DON'T TALK TO ME LIKE THAT.
>> YEAH.
>> I DID NOT TALK TO YOU, ALEX.
>> YOU DID.
>> HOW YOUTALK TO ME
IS ANNOYING.
ALEXANDRIA IS CRAZY, LOUD.
I DON'T LIKE CONFRONTING
'CAUSE I'VE CONFRONTED MY MOTHER
ALL MY LIFE,
AND IT... DOESN'T VIBE WELL
WITH ME.
>> WELL, WE WERE
JUST SHOWING YOU
THAT IT WAS IN THERE.
>> I KNOW,
BUT THE WAY SHE CAME OUT,
SHE WAS LIKE, "OKAY, LADIES,
UM, THE THING WITH RAW CHICKEN
IS, UM, YOU HAVE TO WRAP IT."
I KNOW THAT. I COOK.
>> I AM SCARED
TO GET IN A CONFLICT
WITH ALEXANDRIA
BECAUSE SHE COULD WHUP MY BUTT.
I'M JUST GONNA STAY BACK
AND I-I-I'D RATHER
JUST SHUT MY MOUTH AND WATCH,
BECAUSE I-I'M A WATCHER.
I DON'T LIKE TO FIGHT.
>> "DON'T TALK TO ME."
ARE YOU, LIKE, SOME KIND
OF MOTHER OR SOMETHING?
>> NO, SHE'S THINKS SHE IS.
>> LIKE, YOU'RE NOT THE MOM.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU'RE NOT THE ELDER.
YOU'RE NOT SOMEONE
WHO'S SUPERIOR.
>> AND I LOVE HOW--
>> IT'S FUNNY HOW DRAMA HAPPENED
AROUND A PIECE OF CHICKEN.
>> AND THEN SHE HAD TO THROW IN
HER LITTLE TWO CENTS
WHEN SHE WAS
WALKING UP THE STAIRS.
LIKE, "OKAY, ALEX."
DALYA, I FEEL KINDA BAD FOR YOU
'CAUSE IT'S NOT GONNA BE
TOO PLEASANT FOR YOU ANYMORE,
ON MY SIDE AT LEAST.
I KIND OF PITY YOU.
♪♪♪♪♪
(horn honks)
>> TYRA MAIL!
WE HAVE TYRA MAIL!
>> (gasps)
>> "TOMORROW YOU WILL FACE
YOUR WORST CRITIC.
LOVE, TYRA."
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WE ARRIVE
AT THE COLONY THEATRE
IN BURBANK,
AND THERE'S NIGEL,
AND I'M READY TO WORK.
>> SO WELCOME, LADIES.
TODAY'S CHALLENGE
IS ALL ABOUT PERFORMING.
NOT JUST ACTORS HAVE TO PERFORM,
BUT, OF COURSE,
MODELS HAVE TO PERFORM, TOO.
THEY REALLY NEED TO EMOTE
IF THEY'RE GOING TO CONVINCE
THE DIRECTOR OR THE PHOTOGRAPHER
THAT THEY ARE INSPIRING.
'CAUSE IF YOU CAN'T,
THERE'S SIMPLY NO WAY
YOU'RE GONNA INSPIRE
THE CONSUMER.
SO TO HELP YOU BREAK DOWN
THOSE WALLS,
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE YOU
TO ONE OF HOLLYWOOD'S
LEADING ACTING COACHES.
HE IS THE ARTISTIC DIRECTOR
OF THE ACTING CORPS,
AND HIS NAME IS EUGENE BUICA.
>> HELLO!
>> HELLO, LADIES.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO MEET YOU.
YOU KNOW THAT VOICE
INSIDE OF YOUR HEAD THAT SAYS
YOU'RE NOT GOOD ENOUGH,
YOU'RE NOT SMART ENOUGH,
YOU'RE NOT PRETTY ENOUGH?
THIS VOICE INSIDE YOUR HEAD,
I CALL YOUR INNER CRITIC,
AND IT WILL TAKE YOU DOWN
EACH AND EVERY TIME.
>> I HAVE AN INNER CRITIC,
I GUESS,
WHEN I'M P.M.S.'ing A LOT
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE I'M FAT.
BUT BESIDES THAT, I'M--
I'M A PRETTY CONFIDENT PERSON.
>> I NEED YOU TO SORT OF
DEAL WITH THAT INNER CRITIC
RIGHT HERE, RIGHT NOW,
SO THAT WE CAN START BUILDING
ON THAT INTIMATE RELATIONSHIP
THAT'S SO IMPORTANT
WITH THE CAMERA
IF YOU'RE GONNA BE
SUCCESSFUL MODELS.
>> YOU LOOK A LITTLE AFRAID
RIGHT NOW.
>> I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS.
(laughs)
>> ARE YOU A POLITE YOUNG LADY?
>> I AM VERY POLITE. (laughs)
>> YOU WANT PEOPLE TO LIKE YOU?
>> UM, I DO.
>> WOULD YOU SAY
YOU'RE AFRAID OF CONFLICT?
>> YES.
>> WELL, LET ME TELL YOU
SOMETHING.
ACTING, PERFORMING, MODELING
IS ABOUT HAVING THE COURAGE
TO GET INTO CONFLICT.
WHAT'S THE ONE THING YOU LOVE
MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE
IN THIS WORLD?
>> MY PARENTS.
(voice breaks) I'VE ALWAYS
LOVED THEM, BUT IT--
IT TOOK ME A WHILE
TO REALIZE, YOU KNOW,
HOW AWESOME THEY ARE
AND HOW MUCH
THEY'VE SUPPORTED ME.
AND MEETING MY BIRTH MOTHER, UM,
KINDA JOLTED ME,
JUST SEEING HOW GOOD
I REALLY HAVE IT.
AND IT REALLY MADE ME KINDA SAD
THAT I, YOU KNOW,
I PUT THEM THROUGH HELL
IN HIGH SCHOOL
AND I JUST DID STUFF
THAT I SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE.
I'M GRATEFUL
TO MY ADOPTIVE PARENTS.
THEY'RE THE MOST SUPPORTIVE.
THEY'RE PERFECT.
AND, LIKE,
I UNDERSTAND WHY MY MOM
PUT ME UP FOR ADOPTION.
I'M GLAD SHE DID.
BUT, LIKE,
ON THE SUBCONSCIOUS LEVEL,
YOU KNOW, THIS, LIKE,
CHILD IN MY MIND DOESN'T GET IT.
>> HERE'S WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO NEXT, LADIES.
BEHIND YOU ARE EASELS.
YOU'RE GOING TO DRAW
A PICTURE OF YOUR INNER CRITIC.
>> OKAY, LADIES.
SO YOU'RE GONNA HAVE 10 MINUTES
TO DO YOUR DRAWINGS BEHIND YOU.
PROCEED.
>> DRAW HOW YOU FEEL
ABOUT THIS PERSON,
WHAT THIS PERSON LOOKS LIKE
OR FEELS
WHEN THEY'RE ATTACKING YOU.
>> WHEN I AM DRAWING MY PICTURE,
I'M DRAWING MYSELF BECAUSE
THERE'S THIS LITTLE PERSON
INSIDE OF ME
THAT'S ALWAYS TELLING ME
I'M NOT GOOD ENOUGH,
I'M NEVER GOING
TO BE GOOD ENOUGH.
>> OKAY, GUYS,
CAN YOU PUT YOUR PENS DOWN,
PLEASE?
THANK YOU.
>> LADIES, IT'S TIME TO EXPOSE
YOUR FEARS.
YOU'RE GOING TO JOIN ME
UP HERE ON STAGE,
YOU'RE GOING TO HAND ME
YOUR DRAWING,
AND YOU'RE GOING TO FACE
YOUR INNER CRITIC--
A PART WHICH WILL BE PLAYED
BY YOURS TRULY.
SO CONVINCE ME
WHY I SHOULD GO AWAY,
WHY I SHOULD STOP
HINDERING YOUR PROGRESS.
>> MOLLY, YOU'RE FIRST.
>> WELL...
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY
TO THIS PERSON?
>> (voice breaks) YOU NEED
TO STOP THINKING
THAT YOU'RE UNWANTED
JUST BECAUSE YOUR MOTHER
GAVE YOU AWAY.
>> I DIDGIVE YOU AWAY.
>> (cries) BUT YOU HAD TO.
YOU COULDN'T--
>> I DID NOTHAVE TO.
>> I WANT YOU TO GO AWAY.
I WANT...
>> I'M NOT GONNA GO AWAY.
>> YOU NEED TO STOP
POISONING MY MIND.
YES, YOU WILL.
I DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND
THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE EXERCISE
AND ACTUALLY MAKING IT
IN MODELING.
I HAVE TO BE THE ONE
WHO BELIEVES IN MYSELF
TO HELP OTHERS
SEE ME IN THE SAME WAY.
YOU KNOW, I HAVE TO BE CONFIDENT
AND I HAVE TO BELIEVE
THAT I CAN DO IT
SO OTHER PEOPLE CAN SEE IT, TOO.
>> (voice breaks) WHY ISN'T
ANYTHING I EVER DO
GOOD ENOUGH FOR YOU?
>> BECAUSE YOU'RENOT
GOOD ENOUGH FOR ME.
>> I AMGOOD ENOUGH FOR YOU.
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
>> MODELING IS MY LIFE
RIGHT NOW,
AND I AMGOOD ENOUGH TO DO IT,
AND I DON'T GIVE A DAMN
WHAT YOU THINK OF ME.
>> GOOD.
>> (crying) YOU THINK
YOU CAN'T MODEL
BECAUSE YOU HAVE A BABY FACE
AND BECAUSE PEOPLE TELL YOU
YOUR VOICE IS TOO HIGH.
BUT YOU CAN DO ANYTHING
YOU WANNA DO.
>> THIS COMPETITION
IS DEFINITELY HIGH-STRESS.
THERE'S A TON OF GIRLS
LIVING IN ONE SPACE TOGETHER.
I THINK EVERYONE GOT A CHANCE
TO RELEASE WHATEVER IT WAS
THAT THEY'RE FEELING.
>> WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY
TO ME?
>> ALL MY LIFE,
I'VE HAD TO LISTEN TO YOU
IN MY HEAD.
(crying) I HAD TO LISTEN
TO ALL THESE VOICES IN MY HEAD
AND SUFFER THROUGH NIGHTMARES
EVER SINCE AUSTIN DIED,
ALL BECAUSE OF YOU.
THE MEN IN MY LIFE
THAT WERE SUPPOSED TO BE HERE
FOR THIS MOMENT
ARE NOT HERE WITH ME.
MY AUSTIN AND SHASIN ARE DEAD.
AND WHAT AM I SUPPOSED TO DO?
(sobbing)
>> I'VE NEVER HAD TO DEAL
WITH A DEATH
THAT WAS EXTREMELY CLOSE TO ME,
AND I DON'T EVEN WANT
TO THINK ABOUT IT.
I WOULD NEVER BE ABLE
TO GO THROUGH
WHAT ONDREI'S GONE THROUGH
AND BE IN THIS COMPETITION.
>> (sniffles) IT'S NOT FAIR.
IT'S--IT'S NOT.
WHY SHOULD I HAVE TO GO THROUGH
ALL THAT BECAUSE OF YOU?
THAT CHALLENGE--
IT WAS UNCOMFORTABLE FOR ME.
IT WAS, BECAUSE I DIDN'T EXPECT
TO GO THAT DEEP
INTO MY EMOTIONS,
ESPECIALLY DEALING WITH
A TOUCHY SUBJECT
SO FAR AS MY BROTHERS
ARE CONCERNED AND THEIR DEATHS,
BECAUSE IT'S LIKE...
SOMETHING THAT YOU DON'T WANT
TO THINK BACK ON.
>> LISTEN, I KNOW IT WAS
A PAINFUL ROUTINE,
BUT ULTIMATELY,
GOING THROUGH ALL OF THIS
EXPOSES WHO YOU REALLY ARE.
AND IF YOU CAN,
THE CAMERA CAN CAPTURE IT.
TRULY, IT'S YOUR HUMANITY
THAT MAKES YOU BEAUTIFUL.
IF YOU HIDE THAT,
IF WE CAN'T SEE THAT,
THEN YOU'RE JUST ANOTHER MODEL,
JUST ANOTHER GIRL,
YOU'RE JUST ANOTHER
PRETTY FACE IN THE CROWD.
WHAT EACH AND EVERY ONE
OF YOU HAS IS A STORY,
AND IT MAKES YOU SPECIAL.
>> DOING THIS EXERCISE,
IT WAS REALLY CATHARTIC.
I REALIZED THAT
I DO DESERVE TO BE HERE
AND I CAN MODEL,
AND I FEEL LIKE
THERE'S WEIGHT OFF MY SHOULDERS
AND THAT I REALLY DID
WORK THROUGH MY PROBLEMS.
>> YOU ALL DID
SUCH AN AMAZING JOB.
IN FACT, J.ESTINA JEWELERS
HAVE DECIDED TO GIFT
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF YOU
WITH A BEAUTIFUL PAIR
OF EARRINGS FROM
THE J.ESTINA TIARA COLLECTION.
>> I AM SO EXCITED
TO HAVE THE EARRINGS.
I THINK WE ALL DESERVED IT
BECAUSE WE WENT THROUGH HECK.
AND SO I JUST FEEL
ON TOP OF THE WORLD.
I CAN'T WAIT TO PUT 'EM ON
AND WEAR THEM
WITH A BEAUTIFUL DRESS.
I'M SO EXCITED.
>> GROUP HUG. COME ON.
>> THANKS!
>> I WANNA HUG NIGEL!
>> WELL DONE, LADIES.
>> THANK YOU.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> THAT WAS AWESOME.
>> THAT WAS REALLY GOOD...
>> IT WAS.
>> WHAT HAPPENED TO US EARLIER?
YEAH.
I-IT HURT TO TALK ABOUT
STUFF LIKE THAT.
I HAVE BEEN AWAY
FROM MY FAMILY BEFORE,
BUT NOT TO THIS EXTENT.
AND THIS IS, LIKE,
THE BEST FEELING EVER,
BEING ABLE TO GROW
AND LIVE WITH OTHER PEOPLE
THAT I'VE NEVER LIVED WITH
BEFORE, BECAUSE I DO NEED
TO BE INDEPENDENT.
HOW AM I EVER GONNA BE
AN ADULT WOMAN
IF I'M STILL 25 YEARS OLD,
LIVING WITH MY PARENTS?
♪♪♪♪♪
>> TODAY HAS BEEN...
A TOUGH DAY FOR ME.
I FEEL LIKE
I'M JUST A LITTLE OVERWHELMED.
YOU KNOW, I'M JUST THINKING,
YOU KNOW, WHETHER OR NOT
I WANNA BE HERE.
(dialing)
(phone rings)
>> Hello?
>> HEY.
>> Hey.
>> (sniffles)
>> Are you crying?
>> (voice breaks) YEAH.
(cries)
IT'S JUST VERY STRESSFUL
THINKING ABOUT, LIKE,
WHAT I'VE BEEN THROUGH
AND STUFF LIKE THAT--
LIKE SHASIN AND, LIKE,
THE DEATH OF HIM.
SO, LIKE, THAT BEEN, LIKE,
BROUGHT UP A LOT.
YOU KNOW,
I THOUGHT I WAS, LIKE...
MENTALLY, I WAS GOING TO BE ABLE
DEAL WITH IT, BUT I CAN'T.
(sniffles)
>> Whatever decision you make,
we all gonna stand behind you
no matter what.
>> (sighs deeply)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> (mouths word)
>> HELLO!
>> GOOD MORNING, GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> WELL,
WELCOME TO SMASHBOX STUDIOS.
WELL, YOU KNOW,
THE FASHION INDUSTRY
IS CONSTANTLY ABUZZ,
CREATING DYNAMIC IMAGERY
FOR HIGH FASHION
EDITORIAL ADVERTISING,
AND SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING DRASTIC
TO EXCITE PEOPLE
TO WANT THAT PRODUCT.
FOR TODAY'S PHOTO SHOOT,
YOU GUYS WILL BE WORKING
WITH SOME OF THE BUSIEST BEES
IN THE BUSINESS.
(bees buzzing)
>> OH, MY GOSH.
>> SO WHILE JAY IS TALKING,
WE HEAR, LIKE, BUZZING.
>> BZZ!
(smack)
>> I MEAN, LITERALLY, BEES.
(bees buzzing)
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> YEAH.
>> OOH!
>> OH, MY LORD.
WE'RE DEALING WITH BEES TODAY.
>> I HOPE THEY DON'T STING ME.
I'M REALLY NERVOUS.
>> YOU GUYS WILL BE WEARING
JEWELRY COVERED IN PHEROMONES
ATTRACTING THE BEES.
BUT I NEED YOU GUYS TO STAY CALM
THROUGH ALL OF THIS
AND TRUST YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER.
HE'S A MASTER AT BEAUTY SHOTS
AND BEAUTY LIGHTING--
MR. MIKE ROSENTHAL.
>> YAY!
>> SO THIS IS GONNA BE
SOMETHING REALLY EXCITING.
AND REALLY WANNA SEE YOU GUYS
BE ALL ABOUT THE SHOT
AND NOT ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON AROUND YOU.
>> SO COME ON.
LET'S GO TO HAIR AND MAKEUP.
>> THERE'S, LIKE,
SOME FABULOUS GIRLS HERE,
AND IT MAKES THIS COMPETITION
SO MUCH HARDER
BECAUSE I'M COMPARING MYSELF
TO OTHER PEOPLE,
WHICH IS SO, LIKE, DESTRUCTIVE.
(bees buzzing)
>> I'M SCARED. I JUST, LIKE--
I THINK I'M GONNA SWELL UP.
I AM ALLERGIC TO BEES.
I SWELL UP AND GET
THESE BIG RED WELTS ON MY ARM.
BUT I'M MORE NERVOUS
ABOUT TAKING A GOOD PICTURE
THAN I AM ABOUT THE BEES,
>> THIS IS MY BEEKEEPER OUTFIT.
>> IS IT?
>> I'M NOT SURE
IF YOU GUYS KNOW--
WE'RE GONNA PUT COTTON
IN YOUR EARS AND YOUR NOSE
SO THE BEES DON'T GO, LIKE,
UP YOUR NOSE OR IN YOUR EARS.
OKAY, THIS IS SERIOUS MODE NOW.
WE'RE ACTUALLY
LETTING THE BEES OUT.
(bees buzzing)
>> CAN SOMEBODY
JUST STAND RIGHT NEXT TO HER
AND MAKE SURE NOBODY--
NO BEES GO IN HER MOUTH?
SORRY. (chuckles)
THAT WOULD BE
THE MOST DISGUSTING THING EVER.
>> IT IS A CREEPY FEELING
TO HAVE THOSE LITTLE BEES
TICKLING YOU.
LIKE, I WANTED
TO TAKE MY SHIRT OFF, TOO,
'CAUSE, LIKE, SERIOUSLY,
THEY WERE CRAWLING IN THERE
AND, LIKE, HANGING OUT
INSIDE MY SHIRT. (laughs)
♪♪♪♪♪
(camera shutter clicking)
>> GOOD.
>> OH, MY GOSH. IT'S STUNNING.
(camera shutter clicking)
>> YEAH, THAT'S GREAT.
GOOD.
>> THE BEE THING, LIKE,
FREAKED ME OUT A LITTLE BIT.
LIKE, UGH!
I STILL FEEL THEM, LIKE,
CRAWLING ON ME.
>> THE MORE BEES, THE BETTER.
THIS IS GREAT.
>> OH, GOD.
(camera shutter clicking)
>> DON'T JUST HAVE YOUR HAND
FLOATING IN THE AIR.
IS THIS THING MEAN "I GOT IT"?
FOR SARA, I JUST SENSED
THIS AWKWARD,
NOT COMFORTABLE IN HER OWN SKIN
PERSON.
(bees buzzing)
>> HELLO THERE.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I THINK THIS EXERCISE
THAT WE DID WITH EUGENE
IS REALLY GONNA HELP ME
WITH MY PHOTO SHOOT.
I FEEL LIKE I'M GONNA
BE MORE CONFIDENT IN MYSELF.
I FEEL LIKE I CAN DO THIS,
I'M A STRONG PERSON.
>> HEY, NICOLE,
YOUR EYES LOOK EXTREMELYSLEEPY.
>> OKAY.
>> IT'S LIKE, IS SHE AWAKE?
>> RIGHT.
>> OKAY.
>> NICOLE--
IT WAS A LITTLE BORING.
IT WAS A LITTLE LACKLUSTER.
HER PHOTOS WERE JUST...
OKAY.
>> I'M SITTING IN THE BEE TENT,
AND OF COURSE THERE'S BEES
CRAWLING ALL UP THE NECKLACE,
ONTO MY FACE.
BUT I DON'T HAVE A CHOICE.
I HAVE TO DO IT.
>> GOOD.
BEAUTIFUL.
>> OOH, I KINDA LIKE THAT.
>> GOOD.
>> ALL RIGHT, DOMINIQUE.
>> BEING IN THE BOTTOM TWO
LAST WEEK IS THE REASON WHY
I'M SO NERVOUS
ABOUT THIS PHOTO SHOOT.
SO I'M JUST TRYING TO RELAX
AND THINK ABOUT
WHO DOMINIQUE REALLY IS.
>> HEY, DOMINIQUE,
DON'T SWALLOW
INTO YOUR SHOULDERS.
(bees buzzing)
>> GOOD.
DON'T BE AFRAID
OF DOING SOMETHING
THAT LOOKS WEIRD,
JUST WHATEVER YOU CAN
TO GET A DIFFERENT SHAPE
IN YOUR BODY.
>> HANNAH, WHAT WAS
PART OF YOUR EXERCISE THIS WEEK?
WHO WAS THE PERSON YOU DREW?
>> JUST A REALLY DARK...
(voice breaks) PART OF MYSELF.
THIS IS JUST, LIKE,
REALLY HIGH PRESSURE,
AND I COULDN'T STOP CRYING
BECAUSE, LIKE,
I WAS JUST, LIKE, FREAKING OUT.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> BEAUTIFUL.
>> HANNAH WAS A SOBBING MESS,
LIKE, CRYING HER EYES OUT.
AND I'M SITTING THERE LIKE,
"YOU'RE PATHETIC."
AND IT REALLY IRRITATED ME.
>> AND I LOVE THE TEARS.
THEY--ACTUALLY, IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
OH! BEAUTIFUL!
>> GOOD.
REMEMBER, USE YOUR ANGLES
'CAUSE WE'RE ONLY SEEING
SHOULDERS UP.
>> I'M NOT AFRAID OF ANYTHING.
I WAS JUST LIKE,
ALL RIGHT, LET'S HURRY UP
AND LET'S DO THIS 'CAUSE I HAVE
ALL THESE IDEAS IN MY HEAD,
AND IF SOMEONE DOES 'EM
BEFORE ME, I WILL KILL.
>> GOOD.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THIS IS CRAZY, AND I LIKE IT.
I'M DEFINITELY
PUTTING PRESSURE ON MYSELF
'CAUSE I GOT FIRST PHOTO
LAST WEEK.
I WANNA GET FIRST PHOTO
EVERY WEEK.
LIKE, I HATE BEING SECOND EVEN.
YOU KNOW, I WANNA BE FIRST.
>> JUST ONE THING, MOLLY.
YOU'RE TRYING
TO GIVE ME INTENSITY
INSTEAD OF FEELING IT.
>> GOOD.
>> MUCH BETTER.
>> I WANT THE $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL,
SO I GOT INTO THIS ZONE
TO WHERE I'M NOT GONNA THINK
ABOUT THE BEES,
AND I'M GONNA FOCUS ON MY EYES
BECAUSE MY EYES TEND
TO LOOK A LITTLE DEAD.
>> GOOD.
NEXT, JUST GIVE ME
A LITTLE SOMETHING IN THE EYES,
OKAY?
>> I GOT TO WATCH DALYA,
WHO WAS VERY TIMID AT FIRST,
AND IT MADE HER LOOK LIKE
SHE DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT SHE WAS DOING,
AND SHE WAS
JUST KIND OF LAME TO ME.
SO I HOPE THAT SHE GOES HOME.
>> OH, MY LORD.
I SEE ALL THE BEES
ALL OVER THE EARRINGS,
AND I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS
BUT I'M READY TO GET THE SHOW
ROCKING AND ROLLING.
THESE AREN'T, LIKE,
KILLER BEES, ARE THEY?
>> ALL RIGHT, JACLYN.
>> GOOD.
(camera shutter clicking)
>> THAT'S REALLY PRETTY,
THAT LAST ONE.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> GOOD.
>> I LOVE HOW FEARLESS YOU ARE
DIRECT TO CAMERA.
BRITTANI IS
A CONSUMMATE PROFESSIONAL.
INTENSITY, FEARLESS,
STARES AT THE CAMERA.
I MEAN,
SHE'S KNOWS HOW TO WORK IT.
>> IT'S A LITTLE HARD
DEALING WITH ALL THE EMOTIONS,
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE HAD
YESTERDAY'S CHALLENGE
AT THE THEATRE.
AND THAT'S HARD TO DEAL WITH,
THINKING ABOUT THAT
AND THEN HAVING TO DO
A PHOTO SHOOT.
>> YOU WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT YOU ARE TRYING TO CONNECT
AS OPPOSED TO JUST BE THERE
AND JUST BE PRETTY.
>> ONDREI--SHE'S DEFINITELY
SOMEONE THAT I WOULD SAY
I WOULD BOOK HER.
SHE'S GOT
THIS VERY STRIKING LOOK.
BUT I WAS FLOORED
TO SEE HER PERFORMANCE
JUST FALL FLAT.
HEY, ONDREI?
>> YES?
>> YOU ARE JUST
GOING THROUGH THE MOTIONS
RIGHT NOW.
I THINK THAT WALL
THAT YOU WORKED ON THIS WEEK
TO BRING DOWN IS ALL THE WAY UP.
SO WE NEED TO INWARDS,
DROP THAT WALL.
OKAY?
(camera shutter clicking)
>> THAT'S REALLY DISAPPOINTING.
>> OKAY.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> (screaming)
>> (gasps)
>> "TOMORROW YOU WILL
MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY 12 WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPE OF BECOMING..."
>> "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
>> WHOO!
>> I GET NERVOUS
EVERY TIME WE GO TO PANEL.
YEAH, YOU MIGHT FEEL CONFIDENT
ABOUT WHAT YOU DID THIS WEEK,
BUT YOU NEVER KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR.
IF THEY DON'T LIKE IT,
IT'S YOUR TIME TO GO.
>> DURING THE PHOTO SHOOT TODAY,
I WAS JUST LIKE--
I WAS HERE, BUT I WASN'T HERE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
SO I WANTTO BE HERE,
BUT I'M NOT READYTO BE HERE.
>> YEAH,
>> IT'S A DIFFERENCE.
I THINK I CAME TO
THIS COMPETITION
UNAWARE OF--OF A LOT OF THINGS.
I'M THINKING THAT
I PUT MYSELF IN A POSITION
THAT I WASN'T READY FOR.
SO I CAN'T PREDICT TOMORROW.
(crying) AND, LIKE,
MY TWO BROTHERS ARE GONE,
AND IT'S JUST
MY SISTER AND MY MOM.
>> YOU WANNA MAKE
THE RIGHT DECISIONS.
>> ONDREI IS UNDER
A LOT OF STRESS.
HOWEVER, IF I EVER LOST
ONE OF MY SISTERS.
I WOULDN'T BE, LIKE,
TRYING TO WIN
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
SO I FEEL LIKE
SHE SHOULD'VE KNOWN THAT
BEFORE SHE EVEN CAME HERE.
SO JUST GO BECAUSE
WE DON'T WANT YOU
JUST TAKING OVER THIS SPOT
WHEN YOU DON'T WANT IT.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I HAVE TO CATCH A FLIGHT,
SO I'M STILL GETTING DRESSED
ON SET.
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> (laughs) I'M GETTING DRESSED
'CAUSE I HAVE A FLIGHT TO CATCH,
SO I'M GETTING DRESSED
ON SET TODAY. DO YOU SEE THIS?
I'M A--I'M TOTALLY MESSED.
YOU THOUGHT THIS WAS
MY DRECKIDNESS?
YOU THOUGHT I WAS GONNA
WEAR THESE SHOES? NO, CHILD.
YOU CAN'T BE SO POLITE, ANDRÉ.
YOU HAVE TO SAY, "GIRL,
GO BACK TO YOUR DRESSING ROOM!"
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> WELL, HELLO, LADIES.
>> HI.
>> WELCOME TO ANOTHER JUDGING.
YOU KNOW OUR PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH ONE OF THE TOP
MODEL MANAGEMENT COMPANIES
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD--
IMG MODELS,
AND A SPREAD IN...
(imitates Italian accent)
"VOGUE ITALIA"...
(normal voice) A COVER
OF "BEAUTY IN VOGUE,"
AND YOU GET FEATURED
ON "VOGUE ITALIA'S" WEB SITE,
vogue.it,
AND OF COURSE,
A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
YOU KNOW OUR JUDGES.
THE FIRST--NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER...
>> LADIES.
>> ANDRÉ LEON TALLEY,
THEMOST INFLUENTIAL PERSON
IN ALL OF FASHION, I SAY...
>> WOW!
>> AND SUPERMODEL ALEK WEK.
AND ALEK WAS DISCOVERED
AT A TOWN FAIR,
WALKING DOWN THE STREET, GIRL,
IN LONDON.
AND SHE'S WORKED FOR CHANEL
AND DIOR AND GALLIANO
AND A MILLION OTHER THINGS
AND MILLIONS OF MAGAZINE COVERS
AND ALL TYPES OF STUFF.
ARE WE READY TO START?
>> YES.
>> OKAY.
SO, JUDGES,
THE GIRLS HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
IT WAS A BEAUTY SHOT.
AND CONTRARY TO POPULAR BELIEF,
A BEAUTY SHOT
DOESN'T MEAN "BEAUTIFUL."
IT JUST MEANS
A SHOT OF YOUR FACE.
OKAY?
IT WASN'T JUST ANY BEAUTY SHOT.
THE GIRLS WERE SHOT WITH BEES.
>> OH, SO IT WAS "BEE-TIFUL."
>> IT WAS BEE-TIFUL, YES.
FLYING ALL OVER THEIR FACES.
>> WOW.
>> AND, ONDREI, YOU'RE FIRST.
SO, ONDREI,
YOU LOOK ABSOLUTELY STUNNING.
>> LOVELY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> LOVELY, LOVELY.
SO HOW WERE THE BEES FOR YOU?
>> THIS PHOTO SHOOT
DID NOT GO SO WELL.
I BELIEVE THAT I DID NOT GIVE
MY 100% ALL
BECAUSE I'M NOT 100% MYSELF.
AND I'M VERY AWARE OF, YOU KNOW,
THE OPPORTUNITY
THAT YOU HAVE GIVEN ME,
AND I'M VERY BLESSED
TO EVEN BE HERE,
BUT I MUST SAY THAT
I DON'T FEEL RIGHT BEING HERE
WHEN I KNOW I'M GOING THROUGH
A TOUGH TIME IN MY LIFE.
AND I THOUGHT THAT I WAS
GONNA BE STRONG ENOUGH
TO HANDLE IT,
AND I CAN'T RIGHT NOW, SO...
>> SO YOU WANT TO GO HOME?
>> I DO.
>> OKAY.
>> ONDREI,
YOU'RE A BEAUTIFUL GIRL.
YOU'VE HAD A VERY TOUGH
AND DIFFICULT TIME.
I THINK WE UNDERSTAND
YOU HAVE A UNIQUE SITUATION.
GOOD LUCK.
>> THANK YOU.
>> GOOD LUCK.
NOW THE ONE THING
THAT WE WILL DO AS JUDGES IS,
WE HAVE TO EVALUATE
YOUR PHOTO.
>> RIGHT.
>> IF ONDREI'S PHOTO IS
THE WORST PHOTO THIS WEEK,
THERE WILL BE NO ELIMINATION.
IF SHE DOES NOT HAVE
THE WORST PHOTO,
THERE WILL BE
AN ELIMINATION TONIGHT.
WELL, GOOD LUCK, ONDREI.
>> THANK YOU.
HEY, DON'T CRY. PLEASE DON'T.
>> WE LOVE YOU.
>> FOR REAL.
>> MWAH.
>> YOU'RE IN OUR PRAYERS.
>> GOOD LUCK WITH EVERYTHING.
>> OKAY.
UP NEXT IS KASIA.
SO KASIA IS
OUR ONLY PLUS-SIZE MODEL
THIS CYCLE.
>> TOO MUCH FASHION, KASIA.
OVERKILL.
TAKE OFF THAT BELT.
THAT'S IT. THROW IT DOWN.
>> THAT WAS DELIBERATE.
I THINK SHE SET
THAT WHOLE THING UP.
>> SHE'S LIKE, "I'M GONNA
UNDRESS MYSELF FIERCELY."
>> (laughs)
>> HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> GORGEOUS.
ABSOLUTELY STUNNING.
>> I JUST LOVE THE WAY
ALL THE BEES ON THE EARRING,
AND THEN YOU'VE GOT
JUST THAT ONE
THAT'S RIGHT THERE.
>> I'M ALWAYS LOOKING
FOR THE MERGE OR CONVERGENCE
OF FASHION AND ART.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, GUYS.
UP NEXT IS MIKAELA.
HI.
>> HI.
>> HI, MIKAELA.
>> YOU LOOK FANTASTIC.
>> I DO? THANK YOU.
>> YEAH. I THINK YOU LOOK
REALLY CHIC, CLEAN.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> VERY STRIKING.
GREAT EYE CONTACT.
>> I THINK IT'S WONDERFUL
HOW YOU JUST HAVE THIS CALM.
REALLY STUNNING.
>> I LIKE IT.
IT'S LIKE YOU DON'T EVEN FEEL
YOU HAVE THE BEES ON YOU.
>> YOUR FILM--
GIRL, YOU WERE SO DEAD
UP IN YOUR EYES
EXCEPT FOR THIS PHOTO.
AND YOU HAVE SUCH POWER
IN YOUR FACE
AND YOU JUST LET IT GO.
NEXT IS DOMINIQUE.
>> VERY ELEGANT.
I THINK
IT'S A VERY ELEGANT PHOTOGRAPH,
AND YOUR HANDS LOOK
VERY GRACEFUL.
>> I THINK THIS PHOTO IS
ACTUALLY QUITE STUNNING,
AND UNFORTUNATELY,
YOUR FILM IN GENERAL WAS NOT.
WHEN YOU DON'T TAKE CONTROL
OF YOUR FACE,
YOUR FACE TAKES CONTROL OF YOU.
YOU WANT TO BE IN CONTROL OF IT.
YOU WANT TO HARNESS IT
AS OPPOSED TO IT
DOING THE THINGS
THAT AREN'T NECESSARILY
THE MOST FLATTERING
TO THE LIGHT.
>> OKAY. THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT IS BRITTANI.
>> IT'S INTERESTING.
IT'S UNUSUAL. IT'S DIFFERENT.
>> IT'S DEFINITELY STRONG,
FOR SURE.
>> (imitates British accent)
ALEK, I LOVE HOW YOU TALK.
>> (laughs)
>> (normal voice) I LOVE
THIS PICTURE, GIRL.
YOU HAVE FOCUS.
DON'T LOSE THAT FOCUS.
>> THANK YOU, GUYS.
>> (European accent) JACLYN!
COME HERE, GIRL.
(normal voice) AND YOU'RE
LOOKING CUTE, TOO,
LIKE A MODEL ON A GO-SEE.
>> YOU HAVE A BEAUTIFUL PROFILE.
I THINK WITH THE HANDS,
IF THE FINGERS WERE
A LITTLE CLOSER, PERHAPS,
IT WOULD LOOK A LITTLE PRETTIER.
>> I THINK IT'S
A BEAUTIFUL PICTURE OF YOU.
I KIND OF WISH YOU HAD DONE
SOMETHING ELSE WITH YOUR HANDS.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT IS DALYA.
LET ME TELL YOU WHY I CHOSE
A PICTURE WITH YOUR EYES CLOSED.
BECAUSE EVERY PICTURE WITH
YOU EYES OPEN, YOU LOOKED CRAZY.
>> (laughs)
>> EVERY PICTURE
OF YOUR EYES OPEN,
I WAS LIKE, "OH, MY GOD.
AM I GONNA HAVE TO JUST GO,
'HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT,"
AND IT'S A BLANK PIECE
OF NOTHING?"
>> SO LISTEN, A QUICK TRICK,
OKAY, IF THIS IS GONNA HAPPEN
TO YOU, AND YOU GET SCARED,
DO THAT CLOSED EYE THING
AND JUST FLICK YOUR EYES OPEN
FOR A MOMENT.
THEN SHUT THEM AGAIN
AND THEN FLICK THEM OPEN
SO THE PHOTOGRAPHER CAN GET
A SHOT WITH YOUR EYES OPEN.
>> STUNNING RIGHT NOW
WHEN YOU JUST DID THAT.
WHERE WAS THAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW
WHAT I WAS THINKING.
>> THANK YOU, DALYA.
ALEXANDRIA.
>> STRIKING.
IT'S LIKE A BIT OF, LIKE,
AN ICE QUEEN, BUT WITH THE BEES.
YOU HAVE A UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE
ON IT, AND I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT.
>> WHEN I LOOK AT IT,
IT'S LIKE BAM!
IT'S FULL-ON.
>> I DO LOVE THE FACT
THAT YOU HAVE YOUR ARMS OUT,
AND IT'S A BEAUTY SHOT,
BUT YOU'RE USING
YOUR WHOLE BODY.
AND OUT, LIKE FLYING,
LIKE SUPERMAN.
BUT YOU DO NEED SOME MORE
INTENSITY IN YOUR EYES.
JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE.
IF YOU'RE GONNA FLY
LIKE SUPERMAN, HONEY,
FEEL THE WIND IN YOUR EYES.
(gasps) OKAY, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> NEXT IS SARA.
>> I WISH THERE WAS
MORE STRENGTH IN THE PHOTOGRAPH.
I THINK THAT YOU ARE
VERY INTERESTING IN FRONT OF US,
BUT I DON'T FEEL THE IMPACT
OF BEAUTY HERE.
>> YOU HAVE
A VERY UNIQUE BEAUTY TO YOU.
YOU HAVE TO OWN IT, THOUGH.
LIKE, YOU HAVE TO
TOTALLY BELIEVE IN YOURSELF.
>> THANK YOU.
>> MOLLY.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE
FULL-ON WARRIOR, YOU KNOW?
>> MM.
>> BUT THAT NECK CAN EVEN BE--
TRUST ME, IT WOULD LOOK LOVELY.
JUST STRETCH IT OUT.
OWN IT, YOU KNOW?
>> IT'S KIND OF NEITHER HERE
NOR THERE FOR ME.
IT'S ALMOST BLAND.
IT'S NOT POWERFUL ENOUGH FOR ME.
>> OKAY.
>> THANKS.
>> UP NEXT IS NICOLE.
ARE YOU READY
FOR YOUR SHOT WITH THE BEES?
>> I AM.
>> HOW WAS IT?
>> THEY WERE REALLY TICKLY,
BUT I JUST THOUGHT OF THEM
AS MOSQUITOES, SO...
>> OH, AND THAT MADE IT OKAY?
>> YEAH. (laughs)
>> MOSQUITOES. EW.
>> OKAY. (laughs)
>> WELL, I WASN'T SCARED
OF THEM THAT WAY.
>> OKAY, HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> YOU LOOK KIND OF OLDER
IN THE PICTURE.
YOU LOOK A LITTLE SOPHISTICATED,
BUT IT'S STILL VERY BEAUTIFUL.
>> YOU'RE MUCH YOUNGER HERE
THAN YOU ARE HERE.
>> SO THIS IS
THE SECOND TIME IN A ROW,
NICOLE, THAT YOU ARE
PHOTOGRAPHING OLDER
THAN YOU ARE.
I NEED YOU TO THINK
"NEWBORN BABY."
SOFTEN EVERY BONE IN YOUR FACE,
AND YOU WILL LOOK YOUR AGE
IN YOUR PHOTOS.
OKAY, THANK YOU.
HANNAH.
>> OH, YOU POOR THING.
>> YEAH.
I-I REALLY WASN'T CRYING
'CAUSE OF THE BEES.
IT WAS--I HAD--
>> WHY WERE YOU CRYING?
>> WELL, I HAD THIS WALL
WHEN I WENT IN THERE,
AND I FELT IT, FOR SURE.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
THINGS HAPPEN.
YOU HAVE TO GO WITH IT.
YOU HAVE TO ROLL WITH IT.
IF YOU'RE CRYING
AND YOU'RE MISERABLE,
EMOTE IT FOR THAT MOMENT,
'CAUSE YOU GIVE THE PHOTOGRAPHER
THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CAPTURE MAGIC.
>> WELL, WHAT HAS
SAVED YOU HERE, FOR ME,
IS THE GORGEOUS ELEGANCE
OF YOUR NECK AND YOUR HAND.
I FIND IT VERY BEAUTIFUL.
IT REMINDS ME
OF A PRIMA BALLERINA,
AND THAT'S NOT A BAD THING
FOR BEAUTY.
>> I DON'T WANT YOU
TO HAVE TO BREAK DOWN
IN EVERY PHOTO SHOOT.
>> ME NEITHER. (chuckles)
>> BUT THIS IS STUNNING,
INCLUDING THE GLISTENING
IN YOUR EYES.
THAT IS BEAUTIFUL, BECAUSE WE
ARE FEELING YOUR INSIDES
COME TO THE OUTSIDE.
>> THANK YOU, GUYS.
>> THANK YOU.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST--MONIQUE.
>> SHANGHAI GESTURE.
YOU HAVE HIJACKED IT
FOR ME, DARLING.
HERE YOU LOOK LIKE
SOME FABULOUS WOMAN
FROM THE SHANGHAI...
>> MM.
>> "FABULOUS LIFE
OF THE SHANGHAI"
OF THE--OF THE DAY
WHEN WE WERE IN SHANGHAI.
THIS IS FABULOUS.
>> I THINK IT'S VERY STRONG.
I THINK YOU LOOK EVIL,
BUT THAT'S OKAY.
YOU'RE EMOTING SOMETHING.
I'D RATHER HAVE EVIL THAN BLAH.
>> BLAH.
>> RIGHT.
>> DO YOU REMEMBER
THAT JOHN GALLIANO DIOR?
>> YES. YES.
>> SHALOM.
>> YES, YES, YES.
>> LIKE, I MEAN, WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT BEAUTIFUL...
>> YOU LOOK LIKE SHALOM HARLOW.
>> YES.
>> EVERY TIME I EDIT YOUR FILM,
I GO, "SHALOM, SHALOM, SHALOM."
>> SHALOM, SHALOM, SHALOM,
SHALOM, SHABBAT, SHALOM.
SHALOM, SHALOM, SHALOM.
>> OKAY, OKAY. SHALOM, SHALOM.
>> (chuckles) NO. ABSOLUTELY.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU, GUYS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> SO NOW IT IS TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE,
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE IFONE OF YOU
IS ELIMINATED.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> SO NOW IT'S TIME
TO DELIBERATE.
ONDREI WENT HOME,
BUT HER PICTURE IS
STILL BEING EVALUATED.
IF HER PICTURE IS THE WORST,
NO OTHER GIRL GOES HOME.
>> OKAY.
>> IF HER PICTURE IS BETTER
THAN SOME OF THE OTHER GIRLS',
EVEN IF IT'S JUST
ONE OTHER GIRL,
THEN ANOTHER GIRL
HAS TO GO HOME.
HERE WE GO.
MIKAELA.
>> I LOVE HER BONE STRUCTURE.
SHE'S DIFFERENT, STRIKING.
WELL DONE.
>> BRITTANI.
>> LOVE IT.
I MEAN, IT ALMOST DOESN'T
EVEN LOOK LIKE A HUMAN BEING.
IT LOOKS LIKE, YOU KNOW,
A PAINTING.
>> GORGEOUS.
YOU WOULD PUT THIS
IN YOUR SALON.
>> ANDRÉ, I DON'T HAVE
A SALON.
YOU GON' BUY ME A SALON?
>> YEAH. I COULD BUY YOU
A SALON.
>> WHERE YOU GET 'EM?
THE SWAP MEET?
JACLYN.
>> I JUST WISH SHE'D
DONE MORE WITH HER HANDS,
ALTHOUGH I THINK SHE IS
A VERY EXTRAORDINARY GIRL.
>> YEAH, ON THAT PROFILE,
IT ALMOST LOOKS LIKE
SOMEBODY PUT THEIR HAND THERE.
IT'S NOT REALLY HERS.
>> KASIA.
>> KASIA. SHE'S INTERESTING.
SHE'S NOT A CLASSIC BEAUTY,
BUT SHE'S--IT WORKS.
>> I ACTUALLY FEEL LIKE
SHE'S LOOKING AT ME.
>> (chuckles)
>> SHE'S TALKING TO YOU.
>> YEAH, SHE IS.
>> DALYA.
>> HAVING A ONE-SHOT WONDER,
SHE'S POTENTIALLY A MISTAKE.
DOESN'T WORK AS A MODEL.
YOU WOULD NOT BOOK A GIRL AGAIN
IF YOU LOOKED AT HER FILM,
AND THERE WAS ONE SHOT--
IT WAS A BLINK SHOT THAT WORKED.
YOU DON'T GET THE JOB AGAIN.
IT DOESN'T MATTER
HOW NICE YOU ARE.
>> ALEXANDRIA.
>> I DON'T FEEL THE IMPACT
OF BEAUTY HERE.
>> I ACTUALLY REALLY LIKE
THIS SHOT OF ALEXANDRIA.
I THINK IT'S KIND OF DIFFERENT.
IT'S--IT'S UNUSUAL.
I LIKE THE, YOU KNOW,
JIM MORRISON EFFECT,
STRAIGHT TO CAMERA.
SHE DID HER OWN THING.
>> SARA.
>> I LIKE IT.
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT
GIVES YOU A DIFFERENT PERIOD.
BUT THAT HAND IS JUST DEAD,
FOR ME,
BUT LOVE THE FACE. SWEET.
>> MOLLY.
>> MOLLY PHYSICALLY IS
A VERY PRETTY GIRL,
BUT I WANNA SEE
SOMETHING MORE THAN THAT.
WHERE ARE YOUIN THE PICTURE?
>> DOMINIQUE.
>> SHE'S REALLY BEAUTIFUL.
I MEAN, SHE COULD JUST CHOOSE
WHEREVER HER ORIGINS ARE,
AND I FIND THAT REALLY BEAUTIFUL
AS A WOMAN.
>> NICOLE.
>> I THINK THAT NICOLE IS
PHOTOGRAPHING OLD.
AND SHE'S BEAUTIFUL.
WHEN YOU SEE HER
IN FRONT OF YOU,
SHE'S YOUNG AND FRESH.
>> SHE'S GOT
VERY STRONG BONE STRUCTURE.
NOW LET'S LOOK PAST THAT
AND SHOW US THE YOUTH.
>> HANNAH.
>> SIMPLY ONE OF
THE MOST MAGICAL MOMENTS
OF THE EVENING.
I MEAN, THE EYES, THE WATER,
THE NECK, THE GRACE,
THE GORGEOUSNESS.
>> ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL
HOW SHE USED THE HAND,
'CAUSE SOME GIRLS WERE
A BIT AWKWARD WITH IT.
>> I THINK THIS PICTURE IS
STELLAR.
>> MONIQUE. THIS IS ART.
>> ART!
>> I WOULD PUT THIS
IN MY SALONAFTER I PURCHASED IT
AT THE SWAP MEET!
>> PURCHASED IT.
THE SWAP MEET.
>> ONDREI. NOT--NOT YOU.
>> (laughs)
>> ONDREI. ONDREI.
THE EYES SAY SO MUCH.
AND I THINK
IT'S REALLY BEAUTIFUL.
>> I-I THINK
THAT ONDREI'S NERVES
REALLY DID GET THE BEST OF HER
BECAUSE I LOOK AT THIS PICTURE,
ALL I SEE IS FEAR.
>> WE'VE REACHED A DECISION.
>> HAVE WE REACHED--
>> NO, WE HAVEN'T.
NO, WE HAVEN'T.
>> YES, WE HAVE.
>> NO, WE HAVE NOT.
>> YES, WE HAVE!
>> NO, WE HAVEN'T.
>> OKAY, WE HAVEN'T.
>> OKAY, WE HAVE.
>> BRING 'EM BACK IN, THOUGH.
>> LET'S DO IT.
>> 12 BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
STAND BEFORE ME,
AND WHO KNOWS HOW MANY PHOTOS
I HAVE IN MY HANDS?
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE GIRLS THAT ARE
STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE BEST PHOTO THIS WEEK
GOES TO...
HANNAH.
THROUGH THE TEARS,
THROUGH THE DRAMA,
AND YOU CREATED BEAUTY.
NOW YOU JUST HAVE TO NOT CRY
NEXT TIME.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
RUNNER-UP FOR BEST PHOTO IS
BRITTANI.
CONGRATULATIONS, BRITTANI.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
MONIQUE.
MIKAELA.
CONGRATULATIONS, MIKAELA.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> THE NEXT NAME
I'M GOING TO CALL...
KASIA.
DOMINIQUE.
SARA.
>> (laughs)
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
THE NEXT NAME
I'M GONNA CALL--ALEXANDRIA.
(imitates French accent) JACLYN.
(normal voice) CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP
DIMPLED BEAUTY.
>> OOH!
>> LOVE THOSE DIMPLES.
>> THANK YOU.
>> MOLLY.
>> OOH. HEART SKIPPED A BEAT,
I SAW.
>> OH, MY...
>> CONGRATULATIONS, MOLLY.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WILL NICOLE AND DALYA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
TWO BEAUTIFUL LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME.
WHAT IS THEIR FATE?
NICOLE, WHAT MAKES THE JUDGES
VERYNERVOUS IS
THAT YOU LOOK LIKE
A TEENAGER IN PERSON,
AND LIKE A TEENAGER'S... AUNTY
IN YOUR PHOTOS.
AND THEN WE HAVE DALYA,
A GIRL
WITH STUNNING BONE STRUCTURE,
ALMOST LIKE A, YEAH,
A YOUNG COLT'S FACE.
AND SHE HAD A GORGEOUS PHOTO
THIS WEEK,
BUT EVERY OTHER PHOTO
WITH HER EYES OPEN--
UNUSABLE,
EXCEPT FOR THE ACCIDENT.
BUT THERE'S ANOTHER FACTOR--
ONDREI'S PHOTO.
IS THIS PHOTO
THEWORST PHOTO
OUT OF ALL OF YOU GIRLS HERE,
OR IS THIS THE PHOTO
THAT IS NOT THE WORST,
THAT WILL SEND ONE OF YOU HOME?
ONDREI'S PHOTO--
NOT THE WORST.
SO ONLY ONE OF YOU
GETS TO STAY.
DALYA.
>> (sniffles)
(crying)
>> WE DON'T LIKE ACCIDENTS,
RIGHT?
ACCIDENTS ALMOST
GET YOU SENT HOME.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> YOU HAVE A MODELING CAREER,
BUT I DON'T WANT YOU
WALKING INTO AGENCIES,
AND THEY'RE LIKE,
"OOH, BABY. MAMA."
BABY IN PERSON,
MAMA IN THE PICTURES, OKAY?
>> YEAH. I THINK I WAS
TRYING TOO HARD.
>> TRYING TOO HARD?
YOU DON'T HAVE TO.
YOU HAVE
ALL THIS BONE STRUCTURE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> JUST LET IT BE.
>> I'M FEELING
A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED IN MYSELF,
BUT, UM, I KNOW THAT MY CAREER
IS NOT GONNA STOP HERE,
AND I REALLY, REALLY APPRECIATE
TYRA'S ADVICE,
AND I THINK THAT I WAS
JUST TRYING TOO HARD.
I WAS REALLY CONCERNED
WITH BEING FIERCE,
AND, YOU KNOW, THAT'S JUST
NOT SOMETHING THAT WORKS
FOR MY LOOK,
AND IT WAS SOMETHING NEW
I TRIED.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
I LEARNED FROM THIS EXPERIENCE,
AND THAT'S ALL I CAN ASK FOR.
♪♪♪♪♪
Captioned by
Closed Captioning Services, Inc.